حسنًا ، إذا كنت لا تستطيع التغلب عليهم ، فماذا عن
تناولهم بدلاً من ذلك ، أريد فقط أن
أحذرك إذا كنت تأكل الآن في الواقع
تشاهد هذا الجزء ،
فربما تريد أن تضع هذا جانباً ،
فقد تبين أن تلك الكتل من
السيكادا الصاخبة بجنون  الذين
استيقظوا للتو من نومهم الذي دام 17 عامًا جيدًا
، يمكن أن يكونوا وجبة خفيفة لذيذة
جدًا ، كما يُزعم أنني شخصياً لم
أجربها ولن أجربها أبدًا ،
لكن شركة حلوى ميريلاند هذه
تبيع شيئًا
لمحبي الحشرات مع حلوى
الشوكولاتة المغطاة
بالشوكولاتة السيكادا
تقول المالكة سارة دواير ،
أولاً ، قم بغمسها في الماء المغلي
ثم دهنها بالزيت والتوابل
بالكاد أستطيع تجاوز ذلك ، أنا مريضة
جدًا بمعدتي أقرأ عن هذا
المعطف بالزيت والتوابل وبعد
ذلك وهكذا تحصل على  تلك القرمشة المرضية
يتم قليها بالهواء
قبل وضعها في الشوكولاتة